six o'clock here on a thursday morning
we're still following breaking news las
vegas fire at the scene of a big fire at
a senior home complex earlier this
morning that's right it was at that low
income housing complex this is on
eastern near washington where hector
mejia joins us live from the scene with
some details in hector this morning
you've been sharing stories of first
responders saving these these people
from the fire what what a what a tough
job for them but they certainly are
heroes
that is true and i have some good news
for you guys
we have fire crews right now confirming
no injuries to report right now great
news right now as we take a look at what
is going on right now we have that fire
and
they tell us the fire started on the
second floor right where you see the
firefighters
outside on the balcony it appears that
it is likely smoking related the fire
started somewhere in that balcony on the
second floor that is according to las
vegas fire and rescue again thankfully
luckily no injuries to report the clock
came out around 3 25 this morning dozens
evacuated from this complex i talked
with one resident she tells me this is
for those who are 62 years or older she
told me that a lot of people who live
here have mobility issues others live
with some form of dementia others
are on a wheelchair so they were worried
about some neighbors who were possibly
not able to get out but thankfully we
heard stories from some residents who
were telling us that firefighters rushed
in helped everybody get out and the
great news right now at this hour is
that everybody got out safely thankfully
no injuries to report wonderful news
right now so we're going to talk with
investigators again right now and
bringing the latest still ahead in the
next half hour for now reporting live
hector mejia live local now